Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Sag mal was machst du eigentlich wenn dir langweilig ist?
Ich recherchiere Käfiggrößen für Elon Musk und Mark Zuckerberg.
Musik Stockbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 465 vom 17. Juli 2023.
Genau, es ist Sommer, es ist heiß und du klickst auf die Internetseite und suchst was?
Käfiggrößen, also ich hab mich mal ein bisschen informiert über Käfigkampf und wie das so,
was da so die architektonischen Gegebenheiten sind, die empfohlen werden und
welche Vor- und Nachteile die bieten und das ist ja wirklich eine faszinierende
Welt in die man da auftaucht,
vor allem wird dann die Welt der Youtube Empfehlungen natürlich relativ düst.
Also es gibt Slap Contest, das ist wirklich ungefähr das bescheuertste,
was sich je jemand ausgedacht hat.
Da stehen sich die Leute gegenüber an so einem Tisch und müssen sich abwechselnd
Ohrfeigen. Also erstmal einen Münzwurf, wer anfangen darf.
Und dann geht das irgendwie, was weiß ich, drei oder fünf mal hin und her.
Darfst dich nicht schützen, ne? Und dann gibt's aber irgendwie so qualifizierende
oder disqualifizierende Schläge, wenn du jetzt irgendwie Faust machst, Disqualifikation.
Wenn du dein Kinn zurückziehst, wirst du disqualifiziert, weil,
natürlich, wenn du das Kinn zurückziehst, dann hindert das den anderen daran,
dich bewusstlos zu schlagen. Ja?
Und das willst du natürlich nicht. Die wollen ja auch, dass da ab und zu mal
einer zu Boden geht, relativ oft passiert.
Also das erscheint mir nicht richtig, weil das findet nicht in einem Käfig statt,
ist sowieso schon mal außen vor.
Also ich sehe gerade Mundschutz geht aber.
Ja gut ne, aber kannst ja auch mal die Gesichter angucken, die bräuchten glaube
ich eher einen Gesichtsschutz, wenn die mit der Nummer fertig sind.
Also das ist so bescheuert, da kannst du auch wirklich nur angucken und sagen so,
ja und dann am Ende kriegen wir 500 Euro oder Dollar oder Rupien oder was auch
immer, also wirklich keine großen Preisgelder für die, naja egal,
also das gibt es, aber genau, ist kein Käfig drum.
Jetzt habe ich aber kürzlich, und da ist der Käfig im Prinzip die Größe einer Telefonzelle.
Was die ganze Nummer, was einfach ein neuer Fakt, also einfach eine ganz neue Herausforderung, ne?
Du kannst jetzt da nicht irgendwelche großen Moves machen mit Anlauf,
du kannst aber auch nicht wegrennen, ne?
Und wenn dein Gegner verhindern möchte, dass du zu Boden gehst,
dann kann der das, ne? Also das sind auch relativ schnelle Kämpfe.
Es ist so bescheuert, was Menschen mit sich antun. Also wie gesagt,
wenn man sich das mit Musk und Zuckerberg vorstellt, will man natürlich den
Käfig korrekt wählen. Und ich bin im Moment für Telefonzelle.
Alter, ich schau mir grad den Scheiß an hier mit diesen Slap Contest,
das geht ja gar nicht. Was ist denn das, ey? Was haben die Leute denn?
Das ist ungefähr so der Höhepunkt an Toxic Masculinity,
das ist so bescheuert und die hauen sich natürlich,
kannst du dir das vorstellen, also erstens sind die regelmäßig bewusstlos,
dann hauen die sich da aufs Ohr, auch ne super Idee.
Jaja das ist wirklich.
Dann sind das auch noch solche Brecher.
Ja klar sind das Brecher.
Das ist so dumm. Das ist wirklich der Höhepunkt an Dummheit.
Das wird sich durchsetzen. Ich sagte ja das wird Olympische Distanz.
Das will sich durchsetzen, das sag ich dir.
Das ist nochmal richtig groß. Aber Telefonzelle ist rein.
Also Cagefight in der Telefonzelle, da muss man natürlich erstmal nochmal eine
Telefonzelle finden, aber das ist natürlich auch geil.
Sag mal so Format Telefonzelle, da musst du natürlich nochmal ein bisschen was
mit den Scheiben machen, nicht dass sich da einer daneben schlägt und hat auf
einmal die Verletzung am Arm oder so, das wollen wir natürlich nicht.
Und wie wir als Berliner ja wissen, hat so eine Telefonzelle ist nicht so widerspenstig.
Das Glas von Telefonzellen ist ja quasi der Boden von Berlin.
So, das Glaswand, Telefonzellen und Bushaltestellen.
Hast du denn so in deinem, bist ja noch sehr jung,
wie viel Raum würdest du sagen hat die Telefonzelle in deinem Leben so eingenommen,
also wie präsent waren die, ich meine hast du viele gesehen oder gab's da nur
noch ein paar, ich weiß nicht mehr ganz genau wann die so verschwunden sind, das ging ja dann so.
Wir haben früher zu noch Impulswahlzeiten, also als es noch... Ende der 80er Jahre?
Genau, da wurde ja den Leuten, also in den USA gab es ja früher Impuls,
früher DTMF oder wie hieß das? Ja DTMF.
Mehrfach Frequenzwählverfahren.
So und da, das konntest du bei vielen Telefonzellen, war im Prinzip,
wenn du das Geld eingeworfen hast, war der Wählblock da gesperrt,
aber dein Mikrofon noch nicht.
Und weil es zu Impulswahlzeiten Leuten Anrufbeantworter mit Fernabhörfunktionen,
die über DTMF gesteuert wurden, verkauft wurden,
musste man diesen Dingern so kleine, wie so eine Größe,
wie so eine Computermaus, Zigarettenschachtel, so Zigarettenschachtelgroße Geräte
verkaufen, wo die halt DTMF-Töne gemacht haben.
Und wenn du die an vielen Telefonzellen konntest, du die an den Hörer halten
und wurde es dann direkt durchgestellt, weil die quasi nur darüber funktionierten
oder auch bei so Club Telefon, wo man Euro reinwerfen musste.
Und da hatten wir eine Zeit lang richtig viel Spaß mit.
Später glaube ich, konnte man dann nur noch oder haben wir irgendwie 0130er
Nummern angerufen, aber ja wir haben auf jeden Fall Telefon Scherze aus der Telefonzelle gemacht.
Ansonsten hatte ein, ich glaube war das erste und letzte Mal,
da war ich so vielleicht, also dass wir wirklich eine brauchten,
ja um die zu benutzen, ja dass es jetzt im Leben etwas war, wo ich sagte ich
muss jetzt telefonieren.
Ich glaube, ich hatte irgendwie eine 10D-Mark-Telefonkarte und das war die einzige,
die ich hier gebraucht habe, weil ich die nicht leer telefoniert habe oder so, ne.
Also das hat da keine Rolle gespielt, aber ich glaube,
da waren wir 14 oder 13, da mussten wir noch in eine Telefonzelle gehen,
da standen wir auch Schlange, so und da gab es dummerweise, da hat ein Freund
von mir, dann wurde von so irgendwelchen aggressiven Idioten angegriffen,
Ich hab mir komplett die Nase gebrochen und so, das war richtig schlimm.
Seitdem sind wir eh nicht mehr in die Nähe von Telefonzellen gegangen.
Ja so klassische Loser Teenager, die im Prinzip einfach nur rumgelaufen sind,
um Streit zu suchen und haben halt beim ersten Moment und das war halt dann
die Warteschlange an der Telefonzelle, bot sich denen halt an.
Ok, das war dann schon so Ende 90er Jahre dann.
Das wird vielleicht auch Ende der 90er gewesen sein.
Also, nur um das ganz kurz noch abzuschließen, für mich einfach ein Hort des Asitums, ja.
Stinken, asoziales Verhalten davor, asoziales Verhalten dadrin,
ja, also wirklich habe ich keine positiven Erinnerungen dran an Telefonzellen.
Und trotzdem heiße ich das nicht gut, dass die wenigen verbleibenden Telefonzellen
andauernd demoliert werden,
aber so ich, ja das war mein,
mein, und natürlich hatte ich jetzt auch, ich lege ja ein bisschen Wert auf
die Privatsphäre im Gespräch und da war Telefonzelle für mich jetzt auch kein attraktiver Ort.
Wieso? Achso weil man da gesehen wird.
Ja, wir sind gesehen, kann man auch hören.
Ja gut, ich meine wenn du heute mit dem Handy rumstehst, dann wirst du ja auch gesehen.
Für mich der richtige Ort, damit Elon Musk und Mark Zuckerberg sich gegenseitig
einen auf die Nase hauen, aber viel mehr verbinde ich nicht mit der Welt.
Ja aber wenn die das machen, dann bitte mit den Original Glasscheiben.
Nee die müssen sich mit Hörern schlagen.
Passt mal auf, dass wir das nicht irgendwann nochmal tun müssen.
Aber vielleicht nochmal so ein Einblick auf Telefonzellen so aus meiner Perspektive,
die ich ja sozusagen auch die 80er Jahre noch live miterlebt habe und das war dann eben auch so,
also zur Erinnerung, Mobilfunk das ging dann halt alles erst in den 90er Jahren
überhaupt los und war dann eigentlich erst so Mitte der 90er Jahre wirklich ein Ding.
Und was noch dazu kam ist, dass jetzt auch nicht unbedingt jeder immer einen
Telefonanschluss hatte, so sprich...
Öffentlichen Telefonzellen kam schon eine gewisse Bedeutung zu.
Nicht ganz so wie in den USA,
wo es ja auch Usos war, dass man die auch anrufen konnte,
ein Feature, was die deutsche Bundespost sträflich vernachlässigt hat,
das fand ich scheiße, es gab ab und zu mal welche, es gab ab und zu,
irgendwann haben sie es mal so ein bisschen eingeführt, aber es war nicht generell so,
weil in den USA war das ja generell so, kennt man ja aus vielen Filmen,
auch Horrorfilmen, Aber die Notwendigkeit,
das gibt ja dann so einen schönen Satz, der damals an allen Telefonzellen prangte,
der klar gemacht hat, welche Bedeutung der hat.
Fasse dich kurz.
Fasse dich kurz, genau.
Denn das passierte schon mal, dass dann halt so Leute vor der Telefonzelle warteten
und die wollten dann halt auch mal telefonieren.
Ja, zum Beispiel die Situation, von der ich gerade sprach.
Nicht witzig.
Ja, nicht ganz so witzig. Es war einfach so der normale Umgang und deswegen
wurde natürlich den Telefonzellen auch sehr viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit geschenkt
und sie wurden auch wertgeschätzt, deswegen waren sie auch nicht so oft demoliert.
Also eigentlich war so demolierte und zugepinkelte Telefonzellen,
das ist etwas, das kenne ich nur aus den 90ern und dann halt bis zu ihrem Ende.
Und vorher war das nicht so.
Stimulierte und nicht zugepinkelte Telefonzellen waren definitiv vor meiner Zeit.
Also insofern war eine Telefonzelle auch ein romantischer Ort,
es gibt ja dieses berühmte… Boah, aber ey, verdunkelt dann, ne?
Verdunkelt.
Nein, ein romantischer Ort im Sinne von, der halt so die Fantasie anregt oder
an dem man auch Momente hat.
Also nicht, also allein, also im Telefongespräch.
Man ist...
Was du überdenkst!
Diese Erinnerung kannst du mir nicht nehmen!
Naja. Und was ich noch hinzufügen muss, deine DTMF ich kann kostenlos telefonieren Methode,
die hat natürlich damals nicht funktioniert, weil es gab kein DTMF,
kein Mehrfrequenzwählverfahren, aber es gab eine äquivalente Methode,
mit der man das auch machen konnte, die dann auch erst später irgendwann nicht
mehr funktionierte, nachdem ihr Post gemerkt habt.
Ja natürlich mit dem Hörerklickern, mit dem Auflegerknopfklickern.
Genau, die Elf wählen, also anstatt eine normale Telefonnummer mit Vorwahl zu wählen,
die ja immer mit einer Null anfängt, hast du quasi anstatt der Null eine Elf
gewählt, so als würde das Wählrad nochmal ein Klackerer weitergehen.
Das ging natürlich mit den W-Rädern nicht, weil die eben bei 10 aufhörten,
wenn du die neu gewählt hast,
aber wenn du dann eben den Hörer 11 mal hintereinander in derselben Frequenz
quasi draufgetackert hast, dann war das technisch derselbe Impuls,
den auch eben diese Wählscheibe gemacht hat.
Und wenn man das irgendwie gut geübt hat, dann konnte man so 11 mal und dann
einfach normal die restliche Telefonnummer weiterwählen. Und warum hat das funktioniert?
Weil das war quasi das Spezialfeature der,
ich hatte fast Telekom gesagt,
der Bundespost-Telefonanschlussmitarbeiter, die also bei dir zu Hause ankamen
und dir einen neuen Anschluss gelegt haben, um dann zu testen,
ob es funktioniert, Ohne dir gleich eine Einheit an Gebühren aufzudingst.
Und deswegen hatten die nämlich ein Wählscheibentelefon mit ner Elf.
Und diese Information ist natürlich dann irgendwann geleakt und dann war das
Feature sehr beliebt. Das war frühes Hackerwissen in den 80er Jahren.
Das muss man mal gemacht haben.
Es geht um 11 Uhr, Mann!
Ja! Hahaha Danke.
Absolut. Okay, ich muss auch sagen, dieses DTMF Ding hat auch wirklich nur bei
einigen Ausgewählten funktioniert und ich glaube,
dass mit dem Durchklickern auf jeden Fall bei mehr Telefonzellen,
müsst ihr jetzt nochmal gucken, vor allem bei diesen Club Telefonen.
Lass einfach mal probieren, stell dich mal in die Telefonzelle und dann rufst
du einfach ganz laut Eleven und dann guckst du mal, ob du automatisch durchgeschaltet wirst.
Eleven.
Da guckt er mal in die Shownotes. Und? Was machen wir jetzt mit dieser ganzen Information?
Also Elon Musk und Zuckerberg sollen gefälligst in die Telefonzelle eingestellt werden.
Ich würde sagen, die Entscheidung ist gefallen.
Ich denke auch.
Können entweder alleine da rein oder zu zweit.
Aber das ist praktisch mit den Glasscheiben, da kann man auch gut zugucken und
so weiter, aber das sieht dann aus, sieht sehr innig aus.
Es gibt ja übrigens auch sehr schön, das sieht man in Berlin auf Festivals und
so sieht man das auch gerne, wenn Leute aus so Telefonzellen Disco machen, kennste ne?
Oh ja, das hatten wir schon auf dem Kongress.
Das ist auch ganz nett, ja. Das ist auch ganz lustig. Kann man schon was mit
machen. Wir haben im CCC Berlin auch eine stehen.
Ich glaube, die ist dafür da, dass wenn man mit dem Handy aus dem Raum raus
muss und keine Empfang hat, damit man nicht so viel auf dem Hof rumschreit.
Aber ich habe jetzt auch ist länger her, dass ich da jemand drin gesehen habe,
aber natürlich will man so ein ikonisches Ding haben.
Wir hatten ja auch mal auf der Datenschleuder diese Luftaufnahme von dem Telefonzellenfriedhof
außerhalb von Berlin, irgendwo war der glaube ich, wo halt ein paar hundert
von den Postgelben, man will natürlich die Postgelbe haben.
Und dann gab es natürlich noch die weiß-grau-magenta-Farben,
die stehen ja wahrscheinlich heute noch.
Die will ja keiner haben. Denkbare Anwendungsfälle. Neben einem Kampf jetzt
zwischen Elon Musk und Mark Zuckerberg.
Stellst du den Garten so neben die Sauna als Dusche? Oder überhaupt als Duschkabine natürlich.
Knüller-Telefonzelle als Duschkabine ist doch total kreativ,
mit so einem Hörer-Dusch-Kopf.
Tim, das ist doch witzig. So, oder was noch ansonsten?
Jetzt natürlich auch, leider übrigens finde ich bedauerlich,
die Telefonzelle hat ja ein Comeback, das weißt du nicht, weil du nicht beruflich
wie ich öfter mal in so neue Büros gehen muss.
Das ist jetzt ein ganz neues Ding, weil im Prinzip die Büroraumarchitektur hat
sich in Richtung des Großraumbüros wieder bewegt.
Und dann war plötzlich Microsoft Teams da und alle waren die ganze Zeit in Calls.
Also das haben diese ganzen Großraumbüros gemacht, die haben halt Telefonzellen wieder gebaut.
Findest du in jedem großraumbüro in der regel besonderes feature zuge also von
innen mit teppich beklebt ja und weil das ding eine telefonzelle ist ist dieser scheiß,
Teppichkleber nicht ordentlich ausgehärtet du kriegst da drin irgendwie nach
drei min drei atemzügen kriegst irgendwie eine migräne attacke für den rest des tages,
weil noch irgendwelche Lösungsmittel ausgasen in dem Ding,
dann sind die aber, die teureren zumindest,
sogar so be-entlüftet, das heißt da ist dann irgendwie noch so ein Ventilator drin,
der dafür sorgt, dass die stickige Luft von dem Großraumbüro in deine Zelle
da getransportiert wird und statt einem Telefon hast du so einen kleinen Tisch,
wo du deinen Laptop draufstellen kannst.
Katastrophe. Wirklich eine absolute Kapitulation der Architektur vor Menschen
oder des Menschen vor der Architektur ist. Also eine absolute loose loose Situation.
Ja gibt es. Schrecklich.
Finde ich also katastrophal.
Also Telefonzellen, Friedhof, Michendorf, Link ist auch in den Shownotes,
da stehen die noch alle rum,
falls ihr euch da eine holen wollt, die sind ganz schön schwer die Dinger,
also das muss man ja sagen, die haben ja alles geschafft, die Leute,
die haben es geschafft die anzusprühen, die Scheiben rauszutreten,
den Hörer abzureißen, Telefonbuch mitzunehmen, da drin alle möglichen Körperflüssigkeiten
zu lassen und so weiter, aber was die nicht geschafft haben ist die Dinger umzuwerfen,
das hat immer nur mit den Dixies geklappt.
So.
Ach, wie schön, apropos Dixies,
genau, 1A Übergang wieder,
1A Übergang, ein Camp, ein Camp-Kopf, genau,
wir müssen mal über das Camp reden und alle die wissen was das Camp ist und
schon mal da waren können jetzt eigentlich diesen Bereich komplett überspringen,
Weil wir wollten jetzt hier nicht zu den bereits konvertierten predigen.
Vielleicht auch zu den bereits konvertierten, denn entgegen meiner ursprünglichen
Annahme gibt es ja noch Tickets.
Für das Camp.
Du kannst für das Camp Tickets kaufen, oder? Lass mal gucken,
oder hat sich das jetzt geändert? Aber als ich schaute, ja man kann im Moment Camp Tickets kaufen.
Es gibt nämlich noch welche.
Ja, was ist das Camp? Das Camp, wir reden vom Chaos Communication Camp.
Wir reden vom Chaos Communication Camp 2023 und das würde fast naheliegen,
dass das so jedes Jahr stattfindet.
Tut's aber nicht, sondern das Camp ist eine Veranstaltung, die nur alle vier Jahre stattfindet.
Das letzte Mal 2019 stattfand und dann elegant die Corona-Zeit ausgesessen hat.
Idealer Termin an der Stelle.
Und das Ganze gibt es seit 1999.
Da ist das nämlich das erste Mal vom Chaos Computer Club überhaupt gestartet
worden. Und vielleicht lohnt es auch noch mal so ein bisschen in die Vergangenheit
zu schauen, wo das eigentlich alles herkommt.
Kennst du die Geschichte eigentlich? Wahrscheinlich nicht.
Ich weiß nicht genau, welche du jetzt erzählen wirst.
Naja, also ich meine, im Prinzip fing das so in den 80er Jahren an damit,
dass quasi der Club ja diesen Kongress regelmäßig ausgeführt hat und das zog
unter anderem auch so eine interessierte Gruppe aus Holland an,
die regelmäßig auf dem Kongress war und das immer ganz toll fand, die Hippies from Hell,
Die dann irgendwann gesagt haben, wir sind zwar nicht so viele wie der CCC und
wir wollen jetzt auch nicht jedes Jahr was machen, aber lasst uns doch auch
mal irgendwas mal machen.
Und haben dann so beschlossen, dass sie mal alle vier Jahre was machen.
Und das ganze fing an mit der Galactic Hacker Party,
das war tatsächlich noch eine Indoor-Veranstaltung, die 1989 stattfand,
mitten in Amsterdam,
ich vergesse jedes Mal wie das Venue heißt, da war so ein bekanntes Venue mitten
in Amsterdam, da waren dann halt auch viele aus Deutschland,
ich war da nicht, muss ich dazu sagen, das hab ich damals noch nicht mitbekommen, aber.
Sie haben sich dieses Versprechen gegeben, alle vier Jahre wieder irgendwie
zusammen zu kommen und was zu machen.
Und dann 1993, als dann quasi dieser vier Jahreszyklus vorbei war,
haben sie dann gesagt, Mensch Leute, wir sind hier irgendwie im Termin im Sommer
gelandet und wir sind Holländer, genau, lass mal auf den Campingplatz gehen.
Und das hat irgendwie alle sehr angetan und diese ganze Idee von lass uns das
einfach mal komplett draußen machen war quasi damit geboren.
Und dann vier Jahre später haben sie es dann auf die Spitze getrieben mit der,
na wie hieß denn jetzt die Veranstaltung, mit der wir haben so viele Abkürzungen
gehabt, jetzt komme ich selber ganz durcheinander.
Auf jeden Fall vier Jahre später war dann der nächste Event.
Die HIP, genau, Hacking in Progress, HIP 97 und das war dann schon viel größer
und alle Teilnehmer waren dann halt mit Zelten da und so wuchs diese ganze Idee
heran und so schwappte das dann eben auch zum Club und dann war dann eben der Beschluss,
dass man sich quasi mit den Holländern so alle zwei Jahre abwechselt und dann
sich quasi in diesen vier Jahreszyklus in die Mitte reinsetzt,
so dass es eben 99 zum ersten Camp gab und dann gab's halt wieder ein Camp und
wieder ein Camp und wieder ein Camp und wieder ein Camp und jetzt gab's das sechsmal und jetzt ist
Die siebte Veranstaltung und die wird wieder da stattfinden,
wo sie jetzt die letzten beiden Male schon stattgefunden hat,
nämlich im Ziegeleipark Mildenberg.
Das ist so knapp eine Stunde rausgefahren aus Berlin und dann ist man da.
Schönes Gelände mit einem kleinen See, wo man auch baden kann und so weiter.
Das ist so der generelle Rahmen, damit ihr mal wisst, wovon wir reden.
Und jetzt habe ich von vielen Leuten gehört, die noch nie da waren,
da gibt's dann immer so ein paar Standardreaktionen so, ne?
Wenn man sagt so, ja hier Camp und so weiter, total toll, kommt doch mal vorbei
und dann kommt sowas, ja nie, das ist ja nur so für Hacker, da muss man ja programmieren
können und so weiter. Im Prinzip die selben Vorurteile, die auch so der Kongress immer hat.
Und dazu kann man halt auch nur sagen, das ist eine sehr eingeschränkte Sicht
darauf, was dort für Leute sich versammeln und mit welcher Intention sie das tun.
Vielleicht kannst du ja mal so ein bisschen sagen, was das Camp für dich so ist.
Ich sag, was es für mich ist, sag ich vielleicht eher, was viele Leute dazu sagen.
Es ist eine enorm abwechslungsreiche Zusammenkunft in der Regel sehr interessanter Leute.
Dieses, oh, da pass ich aber jetzt irgendwie nicht hin, ich bin ja kein Hacker,
ich fahre da. Das ist so die eine CCC-Veranstaltung, wo ich mit vielen Leuten
aus meinem Nicht-Hacker-Freundeskreis hinfahre.
Die da auch hinwollen, die auch seit vielen Iterationen mit mir hinfahren oder
auch ohne mich da hinfahren und sagen, Linus wo bist du geil hier,
weil du eben diesen ganzen...
Do it yourself, Hauptsache irgendetwas Interessantes machen,
Teil von Leuten ansprichst, ja, das, es gibt da natürlich seit vielen Iterationen
jetzt auch immer Badges,
das ist ja so ein bisschen was, was sich bei den Hacker Camps,
auch beim IMF oder so, schon seit längerer Zeit durchgesetzt hat,
dass man also eine, ja, im Prinzip eine kleine Platine hat, die bestimmte Features
hat, um so ein gemeinsamer Löt und Programmierer zu sein, und Programmierplattformen zu haben.
Das heißt nicht, dass jetzt alle daran rumprogrammieren, ganz im Gegenteil,
die meisten machen es nicht oder hängen sich das nur um und stellen ein,
dass das Ding bunt blinkt und den Namen, den eigenen Namen anzeigt.
Es gibt aber, es gibt aber damit schon mal so ein, weißt du,
so ein Ding, mit dem alle was anfangen können.
Ob das jetzt ein absoluter Anfänger ist mit einer Tochter oder so,
die mal löten lernen will, oder ob das irgendwelche C- oder in letzter Zeit
dann Python-Pros sind, die schon mal irgendwie noch eine App dahin portieren
wollen, sowas gibt's da.
Ansonsten werden Villages gebaut,
also Interessengruppen oder Freundeskreise bauen sich im Prinzip,
reservieren sich Bereiche, wo sie dann so einen zentralen Dorfplatz oder sowas
für sich schaffen und da gemeinsam auftreten,
ja, also beispielsweise, was weiß ich, dann die Seabase schafft irgendwie
Großteil ihrer Dekorationen da draußen hin und baut einen eigenen
Dorfplatz oder der was weiß ich Interessengruppe so und so stellt sich da hin
mit ihrem mit ihrem Krepproboter oder oder oder ja also und dann oder oder die
Quadcopter Leute kommen oder
die Funkerinnen und Funker kommen und bringen die längste Antenne mit,
die sie haben und auch noch eine kurze und eine breite so machen so und Und
wollen natürlich auch alle da auf dem Acker dann irgendwie zeigen,
teilen, Spaß haben, aber natürlich auch so ein bisschen ihre Begeisterung teilen.
Und das macht es eigentlich so wunderschön,
darauf spazieren zu gehen, dass es einfach so viele Leute mit so vielen teilweise
echt beknackten Hobbys gibt,
die das alles da auf den Acker geschleppt haben und nur warten,
dass irgendjemand kommt und sagt, erzähl mal, was soll das, damit sie dann halt
mit leuchtenden Augen ihre Begeisterung teilen können.
Das ist für mich und für viele, was ich so höre, eigentlich das CCC-Camp.
Gleichzeitig bauen natürlich auch Villages, in diesem Fall Bühnen,
wo es dann Musik zu hören gibt abends oder auch Vorträge und Workshops.
Und so kann man da einfach schöne Tage verbringen in sehr angenehmer,
gechillter Atmosphäre. So würde ich das Camp heute bezeichnen.
Genau, es ist wirklich ein Sammelort von positiv wahnsinnigen Menschen,
das macht sich zum Beispiel auch ganz gut an dieser Eisenbahn fest,
die ja dort in der Ziegelei, im Ziegeleipark sozusagen, das ist die alte Ziegeleieisenbahn
mit der halt die Ziegel damals hin und her gefahren wurden, beziehungsweise
das dafür zu verarbeitende Material.
Und die ist ja da, das ist ja, wenn da jetzt kein Camp ist, ist das ja ein Museum,
so ein Freiluftmuseum, wo dann diese Bahn auch regelmäßig durch die Gegend onkelt,
das macht sie natürlich dann auch auf dem Camp.
Beim ersten Mal hat's dann nicht lange gedauert, bis dann irgendwie eine Bar
eingerichtet wurde auf diesem Wagen und Bällebad natürlich und das war schon mal ein großer Spaß.
Beim zweiten Camp kamen dann schon die Leute an und haben dann so ihre eigenen
Dresinen und Elektrofahrzeuge auf diese Schienen gestellt.
Ich vermute mal dieses Jahr werden wir da noch eine weitere Explosion in dieser Richtung sehen.
Also alles was in irgendeiner Form wurber gemacht werden kann um dort so einen
technisch basierten Spaß zu entwickeln, das findet dort statt und jeder hat
so seinen eigenen Ansatz dort sich zu verwirklichen.
Und wenn man in all diesen Dingen nicht bewandert ist und wenn man in all diesen
Dingen vielleicht auch meint bisher nicht interessiert gewesen zu sein,
ich kann euch einfach sagen, spätestens dort wird es dann um euch geschehen sein,
weil es einfach sehr interessant ist und da ist dann auch einfach dieser Faktor,
der auf so generell in dieser Hacker-Szene nicht so unterschätzt ist,
nämlich, wenn ihr die Leute fragt, was sie tun.
Überlegt euch gut. Aber das ist das Beste, was ihr machen könnt.
Ihr werdet so umfangreich Auskunft erhalten und so lange mit Informationen versorgt werden,
bis ihr wirklich auch selber anfangen zu verstehen, was da eigentlich geschieht,
weil einfach die Teilungsbereitschaft von Informationen und von Wissen einfach
maximal ist auf solchen Veranstaltungen.
Das ist ja auch klar, man bringt da sein Kram hin, Leute fragen danach, was machst du denn da?
Bäm, so, da kriegt man einfach so viele coole Storys erzählt.
Und über die Tage steigert sich dann dieser Wahnsinn auch.
Dieses Mal muss man auch sagen, finde ich, ist der Zeitrahmen sehr gut gewählt,
weil die Veranstaltung beginnt ja auf einem Dienstag und ist dann am Samstag
eigentlich offiziell beendet.
Das heißt man hat dann auch noch ein schönes Samstag auf Sonntagnächtchen,
wo sich das Ganze alles schön ausklingen kann, um dann gemütlich den Sonntag zum Abbau zu benutzen.
Das führt dazu, dass diese fünf Tage Kernzeit auch wirklich netto sind.
Konsumiert werden können, wenn man am Montag ankommt, was ich euch raten würde spätestens.
Das ist keine Veranstaltung, wo man erst am Dienstagmorgen aufläuft, es geht nicht anders.
Tim, wir müssen glaube ich noch auf eine Sache verweisen,
wir haben jetzt hier so viel vom Camp geschildert, es gibt den Film All Creatures Welcome,
der ja auf dem Camp großteils gedreht wurde,
also auch auf dem Kongress, aber der sehr viel vom Camp auch zeigt und mitnimmt,
wo man nämlich auch den Zug, von dem du gesprochen hast, sehen kann und das ist sehr,
also, wer uns hier da jetzt nicht glaubt,
sollte diesen Film schauen, den hat Sandra Trostel produziert und kostenlos
online gestellt, als Urheberrechts, gemeinfreies Werk, der ist sehr zu empfehlen.
Habe ich in Youtube und in media.ccc.de Link auch nochmal mit in die Shownotes getan.
Ist natürlich allen zu empfehlen, die Vorfreude aufbauen wollen zum Camp.
Korrekt, genau dann ist das ganze natürlich nicht kostenlos,
das heißt man muss Eintritt zahlen und der Eintritt liegt bei,
ist ein bisschen verhandelbar aber liegt so bei 380 Euro erwartungsgemäß und
das wird von vielen Leuten als viel Geld wahrgenommen, ist ja auch viel Geld.
Es ist auch viel Geld, da glauben wir glaube ich nichts drüber.
Für niemanden sind 380 Euro wenig Geld.
Richtig, genau.
Sollten es zumindest nicht sein. Wenn 380 Euro für dich wenig Geld sind,
dann such dir mal einen anderen Job.
Das sind mal ein bisschen normale Preise.
Genau. Gut,
jetzt ist es halt so, solche Veranstaltungen sind teuer und Corona hat natürlich
eine ganze Menge verteuert, weil insbesondere im Veranstaltungsbereich eigentlich
durch die Bank die Preise für so ziemlich alles nach oben geschossen sind.
Andererseits kann man es auch ein bisschen relativieren, weil ich hab ja schon
gesagt, es sind halt wirklich fünf Tage, die man dort vollständig wahrnehmen
kann. Und wenn ihr das Gefühl habt...
Alter, fünf Tage? Was soll ich denn, fünf Tage auf einer Veranstaltung rumhängen?
Ich war schon auf einem Camp, das war nur drei Tage lang, das war viel zu kurz,
dann war das Camp vier Tage lang, das war viel zu kurz, dann war das Camp fünf
Tage, aber leider irgendwie der fünfte Tag war ein Sonntag, sodass es auch kein
richtiger fünfter Tag war, das fühlte sich auch viel zu kurz an.
Und diesmal hab ich so ein bisschen die Hoffnung, dass man jetzt wirklich mal
so einen Speed-Spot erreicht und sagt,
okay jetzt haben wir wirklich mal fünf Tage, weil am ersten Tag sind sowieso
alle immer noch wirre und laufen rum und versuchen sich erstmal zu orientieren,
dann kommt der zweite Tag, dann weiß man schon mal in etwa Bescheid und fängt
erstmal an abzustecken,
was man eigentlich wirklich interessant findet, am dritten Tag reißt es einen
sowieso total mit und man weiß gar nicht mehr, wo oben und unten ist und dann
ist man froh, wenn man so gegen Ende dann auch noch irgendwie so einen Tag hat,
wo man alles nochmal planen kann und jetzt muss ich aber das nochmal machen.
Und das muss ich nochmal machen und das wollte ich auf jeden Fall nochmal hinkriegen.
So und am fünften Tag kann man dann schön runterchillen und sich auch ordentlich
vor allem verabschieden.
Und das ist meiner Meinung nach gut. Und wenn man jetzt mal diese Zeit nimmt,
die angemessen ist und dafür den Preis, dann sieht man,
dass es dann auch nicht mehr so weit weg ist von anderen Open Air Festivals,
die auch vergleichbar Technik auffahren, beziehungsweise eigentlich manchmal
noch nicht mal vergleichbar viel Technik auffahren, weil es wird schon viel gemacht.
Internetinfrastruktur ist natürlich so die herausragende Besonderheit am Camp immer gewesen.
Da kommen wir dann auch auf die Dixies wieder zu sprechen,
weil das Camp ist ja auch so der Geburtsort des Datenklos oder beziehungsweise
der Wiedergeburt des Datenklos,
weil ursprünglich bezeichnet das Datenklo ja das Urmodem,
was der CCC vor langer, langer Zeit mal vorgestellt hat,
damals, als man noch keine Modems so ohne weiteres kaufen konnte,
beziehungsweise die nicht bezahlbar waren, hat der CCC ja so ein Selbstbauset
vorgestellt und weil die Muffen,
das war dann ein Akustikkoppler, um konkret zu sein, die Muffen,
wo man seinen Telefonhörer rein drücken musste, um dann die Verbindung zu den
Lautsprechern herzustellen, um Daten übertragen zu können, weil die halt aus
dem Sanitärfachhandel bezogen wurden, erhielt das dann den Namen Datenklo.
Beim ersten Camp haben wir das aber dann wieder recycelt und deswegen sind halt
diese Dixi Toiletten, also die klassischen Plastik Toiletten,
die nicht die Toiletten sind.
Wohlgemerkt geht nicht auf die Toiletten, es gibt bessere Toiletten.
Ist mal passiert, da wollen wir nicht drüber reden.
Ist nicht einmal passiert, es ist mehrmals passiert. Also man erkennt ein Datenklo
daran, dass es abgeschlossen ist.
Kabel rausgekippt.
Mindestens mit dem Kabelbinder und dass es potenziell von innen beschädigt ist,
weil man die günstiger mieten kann.
Und dass ihr, wenn ihr es wagt, nach unten zu blicken,
was man im Dixie natürlich versucht zu vermeiden, aber wenn da mal so aus dem
Augenwinkel nichts ist, einfach grauer Boden, keine Chemikalien,
keine Fäkalien, gar nichts, dann ist das im Zweifelsfall ein Datenklo.
Und wenn da nur ein ganz klitzekleines bisschen Fäkalien ist,
ohne Chemie, dann ist das auch ein Datenklo.
Kannst du ein bisschen weniger explizit sein?
Das muss einmal anschließend erörtert werden. Im Zweifelsfall gibt es auf dem
Camp, also auf dem Camp sind Dixies in der Regel nicht zur Benutzung gedacht,
sondern wir haben dann andere Toiletten da, komfortablere.
Genau, also das Datenklo ist ein kaputtes Dixi, was dafür verwendet wird als
Datenverteiler, als Kabelverteiler zu dienen.
Da stehen dann Switches drin und so weiter. Das hat sich bewährt,
weil die Dinger bieten Schutz vor Staub, die bieten Schutz vor Sonne,
die bieten eingeschränkt Schutz vor Hitze.
Deswegen ist da meistens noch ein Lüfter drin und nicht selten auch nochmal
Wärmefolie draußen dran, dann glänzen die auch schön.
Aber es hat sich extrem bewährt als günstige wetterfeste Netzwerkverteiler Knoten.
Und um das jetzt zu Ende zu erklären, heutzutage erkennt ihr die Datenfluss
insbesondere daran, dass sich oben drauf so eine kleine wie so eine Fackel befindet,
also eine LED Fackel, die anzeigt, ob das Ding gerade ein Netz hat oder nicht. Haben.
Macht uns keine Schande, wenn wir euch jetzt hier nochmal das Camp den Mund
wässrig machen mit unseren schönen Schilderungen.
So nochmal eine Aussage zu den Tickets und zwar gibt es ja auch noch die Besonderheit,
dass für die Platzierung von Wohnwagen und Wohnmobilen auf dem Festivalgelände
ein Camper-Ticket erforderlich ist, die es nicht mehr gibt.
Das heißt, wenn ihr jetzt beschließt am Camp teilzunehmen, habt ihr im Prinzip zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder ihr holt euch ein Zelt und dann macht ihr das alles im Zelt,
wie viele andere das ja auch machen.
Oder ihr müsst halt dann euer Wohnmobil irgendwie auf dem Parkplatz abstellen.
Aber das ist halt nicht Campingfläche im Sinne von vor Zelt raus und YOLO,
sondern das ist halt ein Parkplatz.
Aber das ist halt dann definitiv auch noch eine Option.
Also da müsst ihr euch dann vorstellen. Also es steht da ja,
hier kann man nicht campen.
Und ich würde, ich kann mir jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass da irgendwie Blockwarte
rumrennen, die Leute aus ihren Autos zerren, die da drin schlafen.
Aber wie ihr sicherlich Ärger bekommt ist, wenn ihr euch auf den Park da stellt,
Vorzelt aufbaut, Duschzelt aufbaut,
noch ein kleines Grill, noch zwei,
drei Zelte drumherum, Grill oder so, am besten noch so irgendwie ein Pavillon
in den Not-, also quasi in die Rettungswege stellen oder so, das geht da nicht.
Ja, aber ich würde sagen, also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass wenn man da einfach normal parkt mit einem VW-Bus, wo man hinten auch drin
schlafen kann, dass das zu Problemen führt, wenn man sich so verhält,
wie man ist. Wir sind ja alle Wildcamper.
Auf einem normalen Parkplatz auch tut.
Aber genau das ist sicherlich eine andere, nicht das, was man sich da unter Camping vorstellt.
Insofern macht es ja vielleicht Sinn, sich zu überlegen, ob man nicht doch mit
einem Familienzelt anreist, das nimmt genauso viel Platz weg und braucht kein Camper-Ticket.
Hat sich jemand was beigedacht?
Insofern erwägt doch nochmal, ob ihr kommen wollt, wir sollten vielleicht auch
nochmal sagen, wann das Camp ist, das findet nämlich statt vom 15. bis 19.
August 2023, wie schon erwähnt, in Mildenberg, in der Nähe von Zedenik,
was wiederum bei Berlin ist, und ja, das lohnt sich, sich da eine Woche Zeit
zu nehmen dafür und dann werdet ihr auch mal wissen, was der Zauber dieser Veranstaltung ist.
In meiner Erinnerung ist es wirklich das Beste.
Camp ist einfach das geilste. Von allen.
Schon ja.
Ich kenne auch selten jemanden, der da zurückkommt und sagt, war nix.
Aber das ist einfach schon eine tolle Veranstaltung, die eben auch davon lebt,
dass da Leute hinkommen, die auch vielleicht was mitbringen wollen.
Oder die vielleicht einfach nur eine coole Stimmung damit hinbringen.
Auf jeden Fall ist es relativ international besucht.
Sehr eigentlich.
Und wird sicherlich nicht langweilig. Wir haben glaube ich schon letzte Sendung
erwähnt, dass wir da einen Live Podcast angenommen bekommen haben auf der Bits und Bäume Stage.
Ah, stimmt ja.
Und du hast Leute gefunden, die mit dir Blinkenlights in das Jahr 2023 teleportiert haben.
Stimmt. Ja das ist so mein Ding. Ich wollte auch mal wieder was zu tun haben.
Hatte ich eigentlich gar nicht erst geplant, aber ich bin bei einer Begehung
auf das Gelände gelatscht und hab festgestellt, dass es da was Neues gibt.
Kann ich auch mal ein bisschen konkreter werden, weil jetzt funktioniert das auch schon.
Ist ja immer so eine Sache mit den Ankündigungen und so.
Lieber erstmal warten, bis man da auch was auf die Kette kriegt.
Aber was wir bespielen ist ein Ziegeleigebäude,
was so zehn nebeneinander liegende großflächige Fenster hat,
so 1,50 mal 1,50 Fenster mit 3,50 Abstand, also so 50 Meter breit,
zehn Fenster nebeneinander.
In dieser Ziegelei wand und die waren
vor vier Jahren noch leer und in der Zwischenzeit sind
die aber wieder mit Glas gefüllt worden und zu
meiner Begeisterung nicht mit Glasscheiben sondern wie das auch ursprünglich
schon war dieser Ziegelei mit Glasbausteinen und in diese 150 mal 150 Lücke
passen halt klassischerweise sind nämlich die Dinger 19 cm 19 cm exakt 8 mal 8 Glasbausteine,
sodass also jedes Fenster 64 Pixel in sich trägt und das halt in diesem perfekten
Layout von 8x8 und als mir das irgendwie klar wurde,
war dann auch irgendwie so, ja, da war die Saat gelegt und dann hab ich mich
mit Björn aus dem X-Heim zusammengetan,
andere sind noch da zugekommen und dann irgendwann ging's so los und irgendwann
haben wir dann beschlossen, okay, wir machen das jetzt einfach mal, egal wie teuer das ist.
Und sind jetzt seit drei Monaten irgendwie dabei, die Technik dafür an den Start
zu bekommen und haben die letzte Woche final installiert bekommen in Form von so Lichtkästen.
Die wir hinter diese Glasbausteinwände packen, sodass wir eben aus diesen 8x8
Glasbausteinen auch richtige 8x8 Pixel gemacht haben.
Das machen wir natürlich mit LED-Technik, macht man das heute.
Die Besonderheit ist, dass wir diese LEDs.
Komplett farbkalibriert gemacht haben. Das heißt, wir haben wirklich mit einem
Farbmessgerät die Farben nachgemessen und feinjustiert mit solchen Tabellen.
Man macht das halt normalerweise so am Computerbildschirm, wenn man jetzt,
sagen wir mal, in der Foto-Retusche arbeitet.
Also wenn es wirklich, wirklich wichtig ist, dass die Farbe,
die du auf dem Bildschirm siehst, auch genau die Farbe ist, die eigentlich gespeichert
wurde, also die sozusagen von der Software gemeint wurde.
Weil wie sollst du dann sonst irgendein Bild richtig retuschieren,
wenn dein Computermonitor die Farbe verzerrt, du speicherst das ab,
retuschierst das in irgendeiner Form, dann kommt es halt woanders ganz anders
raus und das ist ja der Sinn der ganzen Geschichte,
dass du am Ende eine definierte Farbe hast, die dann wiederum von der Druckerei
oder was auch immer dann die Wiedergabe dieses Bildes ist, dann auch korrekt
dargestellt werden kann.
Naja, und wir haben das halt auch gemacht, eben mit diesen LEDs.
Und ich kann ja gar nicht ausreichend beschreiben, wie krass der Unterschied
ist zwischen einem farbkalibrierten Lichtsystem und einem nicht farbkalibrierten Lichtsystem.
Es ist mehr als Tag und Nacht. Es ist wirklich eine ganz andere Nummer.
Also so habt ihr LEDs noch nie gesehen. Die Farben sind so geil.
Brauntöne, alle erdenklichen Graustufen, Übergänge, Grau, ja man kriegt sogar
noch ein diskretes Schwarz hin, also es ist wirklich irre, was man da abbilden kann.
Und jetzt haben wir natürlich den Fall, jetzt wird sehr viel Software geschrieben,
ganze Software ist neu geschrieben worden, ist alles in Elixier geschrieben
worden und jetzt sitzen wir halt mit vielen Leuten dran und bauen dafür so Apps,
das heißt wir wollen das Ding interaktiv machen.
Wir haben so einen Controller, das wird zwei Joysticks geben,
es wird für jedes Fenster ein Button geben und suchen noch nach interessanten
Anwendungen, die man dort machen kann. Wir wollen diverse Retro-Spiele auf das
8x8-Format runterbauen.
Zoom sozusagen, ja, es gibt jetzt schon ein Space Invaders,
was auf 8x8 funktioniert und solche Geschichten, andere Sachen werden folgen
und da das ja dann alles schon viel zu viel Arbeit ist,
dachten wir uns, halten wir uns gleich noch mehr auf und so wird das Ganze auch
eine Klangkomponente haben, weil wir eben über jedes Fenster auch noch einen
Lautsprecher platzieren.
Und damit sozusagen ein 10-kanaliges Soundsystem haben, was letztlich den Content
begleitet oder entweder begleitet der Lichtcontent den Sound oder der Sound
begleitet den Lichtcontent.
Also da ist wirklich, wir haben mehr Möglichkeiten als wir jetzt eigentlich
in dieser kurzen Zeit, die uns jetzt noch verbleibt, ausfüllen können,
aber das motiviert natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch und viele Leute arbeiten dran.
Wenn ihr vielleicht noch Lust habt da kurzfristig mit einzusteigen und ein paar
der noch offenliegenden Aufgaben zu vernehmen, es gibt genug zu tun.
Wir suchen also nach halbwegs fähigen Elixierhackern, die so eine kleine App
machen wollen. Das plagt sich dann alles sozusagen in das System mit rein,
da kann man halt interaktiv was ausprobieren, da kann man mit dem Sound arbeiten.
Gibt's alle möglichen Ideen, die bei uns auch schon vorliegen,
die auch noch so ein bisschen nach Implementierung suchen oder vielleicht habt
ihr auch selber eine Idee. Es gibt einen Simulator im Web, mit dem man das alles
schon ausprobieren kann, wie das dann später aussieht.
Also da ist wirklich eine ganze Menge am Kochen. Ja und wir hoffen natürlich,
dass das Ganze dem Camp zumindest an der Stelle auch nochmal so einen weiteren
Zauber hinzufügt, den ihr ohnehin auf dem ganzen Camp-Gelände auf die eine oder
andere Art und Weise finden werdet.
So genug genug vom Camp oder? Ich würde eine Sache noch kurz erwähnen,
weil bei jeder CCC Veranstaltung gibt es ja die Möglichkeit des Engelns,
also durch freiwillige Mitarbeit in unterschiedlichsten Aufgabenbereichen zum
Event beizutragen und dort nette andere Engel kennenzulernen.
Deswegen habe ich jetzt noch einige Dinge auch in den Shownotes verlinkt.
Also einmal Infos zu dem Badge, dann den Call for Angels, wo so ein bisschen
das Engel-System erklärt wird, wie man sich da anmeldet und so.
Dann zum barrierefreien Camping, zum CFP, Verkaufsstatistiken für die Verkaufspreise
und dann unsere Help-CCC.de,
wo ihr dann noch weitere Support-Angebote findet, die sich also um Awareness,
Autismus, Inklusion, Und solche Aspekte drehen.
So damit haben wir jetzt auch wirklich genug getan, wenn er jetzt nicht hingeht, sei er selber schuld.
Ja mithelfen, mithelfen am Camp ist auf jeden Fall, ist vor allem,
also nicht nur, dass wir Leute suchen, die uns helfen,
sondern wenn ihr jetzt immer noch so dieses Gefühl habt, so ja Camp meinetwegen,
Geld, Zeit hab ich irgendwie, kann ich mir leisten, will ich mir vielleicht
auch leisten oder mach ich jetzt einfach mal,
Hau mein Zelt da irgendwo hin, aber dann, ich kenn da ja keinen.
Leute, dann engelt ihr einfach und ihr werdet nie wieder so viele neue Freunde
kennengelernt haben in so kurzer Zeit.
Oder ihr habt wenigstens was zu tun.
Naja, erstens man hat was zu tun, man kommt in alle möglichen Sachen rein,
ihr könnt ja selber dann auch entscheiden, wo ihr dran teilnehmen wollt.
Wenn ihr euch mehr für Bühnentechnik AV interessiert, sagt das, macht das.
Wenn es euch eigentlich egal ist und ihr wollt einfach nur jeden Tag was anderes machen,
dann macht ihr halt jeden Tag was anderes oder helft irgendwo in der Küche mit
oder es gibt tausend verschiedene Aufgaben,
es gibt auch immer wieder so neue Herausforderungen, die einfach entstehen,
weil irgendeine Situation aufgekommen ist,
wo man dann einfach eine kollektive Idee gefragt ist oder kreative Umsetzung
und dann ist halt dieses Engelsystem dazu da, einem da entsprechend zu vermitteln.
So ist man dann immer mit irgendwas beschäftigt, lernt auch das Camp und die
ganze Community von allen möglichen Seiten kennen und das ist für viele der
Einstieg schon immer gewesen in diese Szene und das ist toll.
Und wenn ihr noch zu jung seid, um das zu entscheiden, dann erzählt es euren
Eltern und überzeugt die da auch noch mit hinzukommen.
Oder euch einfach abzusetzen.
Ja tschüss, ich bin dann in einer Woche wieder da. So jetzt wollen wir mal wieder
das mit der Sendung machen.
Genau, das wird der Sendung.
Also, herrje.
Großes Thema, also es haben mehrere deutsche Banken, kommen Direktbank,
Deutsche Bank, Postbank, ING, Diber und die Sparda Banken beispielsweise,
Teile ihrer Kundschaft darüber informiert, dass persönliche Daten abhanden gekommen sind.
Und zwar nicht von ihnen selber, sondern aus dem System eines Dienstleisters.
Und dieses System, also das ist der Kontowechsel-Service. Du machst ein neues Konto,
dann hast du jetzt potenziell, wenn du das jetzt seit vielen Jahren hast,
dann hast du vielleicht so ein paar Daueraufträge, die von dem Ding ausgehen
und die kannst du ja meistens noch auflisten lassen, aber blöd ist,
wenn du so SEPA-Mandate hast, die da drauf laufen,
dann musst du ja allen Bescheid sagen, ey übrigens Kontowechsel.
Und das macht ja so ein Kontowechsel so absolut schmerzhaft.
Das einzige was noch schlimmer ist, ist wenn man, wie du oder wie wir,
Support-Eingänge über Dauerauftrag von anderen hat. Das ist das Schlimmste, ja.
Da kannst du ja gar nichts drüber, da kannst du gar nichts machen,
also außer halt hier in der Sendung dann sagen, ey bitte aktualisiert mal euren Tower Auftrag.
So und da hat sich natürlich dann, haben sich Leute gedacht,
boah da machen wir einen Service draus. Und ich hab das auch,
mir wurde dieser Service kürzlich öfter angeboten, weil ich ein paar Konten
eröffnet habe. Und der Service funktioniert
so, ja gib mal, gib mal die Zugangsdaten zu deinem alten Konto.
Dann laden wir da alles runter und werten das aus und dann sagen wir dir,
was wir alles gefunden haben und lösen für dich auch diese Mandatswechsel dann aus.
Also beispielsweise Brief an die Deutsche Telekom, Handyvertrag jetzt bitte
mit dem SEPA-Mandat auf das folgende ändern.
Oder auch, wir übernehmen die Daueraufträge. Sowas bietet dieser Kontowechsel-Service
an und damit erfüllt der natürlich einen Bedarf und wahrscheinlich relativ vielen Leuten eine Freude.
Und ich würde sowas nie nutzen, weil ich möchte das lieber selber in der Hand haben, aber okay.
Nutzen Leute und es ist auch verständlich, dass das ein Angebot ist,
was Banken sich natürlich auch was kosten lassen, weil das eben die Hemmschwelle
senkt, sein Konto zu wechseln oder überhaupt ein neues zu öffnen.
So, und jetzt wurde offenbar dieser, der Betreiber,
das ist die Majorelle, Majorelle, Majorelle,
keine Ahnung, irgendwie so eine Firma, die dann eine Software hat,
die Moovit heißt und die wurden aber irgendwie teilweise gehackt,
da sind noch ganz andere Dinge betroffen, in Deutschland ist es aber jetzt halt
dieser Kontowechsel-Service.
Das ist erstmal sicherlich unschön und wenn man da betroffen ist,
sollte man sich sicherlich auch mal informieren, welche Möglichkeiten man jetzt hat,
da vielleicht irgendwie auch für entschädigt zu werden oder so,
aber eigentlich sprechen wir darüber, weil es einen IT-Experten namens Rüdiger
Trost gibt, der jetzt dazu rät, man sollte seine Kontonummer so schnell wie möglich ändern.
Wer eine betroffene IBAN weiter nutzt, ist jederzeit angreifbar.
Ich glaube, der Mann hat etwas Fundamentales nicht verstanden.
Die IBANs sind jetzt bekannt, die Namen auch. Das ist jetzt keine geheimnisbedürftige Information.
Viele Unternehmen schreiben die auf ihre Webseite. Jeder schreibt die auf seine Rechnung.
Und nur weil jemand deine IBAN weiß, hat er jetzt noch nicht irgendwie dich angegriffen.
Was allerdings Unschönes passiert, auch mit Leuten, die ihre IBANs,
zum Beispiel so Online-Shops oder so, die werden dann gerne mal benutzt,
um irgendwo Kleinstbeträge abzurechnen.
Und da muss man sicherlich jetzt aufpassen, seine.
Kontoauszüge genau anzuschauen, um sicherzustellen, dass da kein Missbrauch
von Leuten passiert, die Kenntnis haben. Ich glaube, man hat nur sechs Wochen
Zeit, sich gegen Fehlabbuchungen zu wehren oder so. Da kenne ich mich gar nicht so genau aus.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall. Es ist ärgerlich, es ist ein Risiko,
was es grundsätzlich gibt. Und ja, Unternehmen haben das.
Viel, Privatpersonen potenziell weniger, aber dafür gucken Privatpersonen,
haben Privatpersonen vielleicht auch nicht so viele Buchungen und können da
mal ein bisschen öfter drüber schauen, ja.
Also ich find's jetzt nicht so fürchterlich, nicht so absolut tragisch,
ja, aber klar, das Risiko hat sich erhöht.
Jetzt könnt ihr euch überlegen, ob ihr ein neues Konto macht,
deswegen könnt ihr ja den Kontowechsel-Service benutzen. Ganz einfach.
Oh man ey, aber da sieht man natürlich auch gleich wieder eine Schwäche des
aktuellen IBAN-Systems in Deutschland oder beziehungsweise generell eigentlich in Europa,
denn dass so etwas überhaupt erforderlich ist, ist natürlich gaga.
Man hätte sehr wohl den Banken vorschreiben können, dass so etwas wie ein Kontoumzug
Teil des Protokolls ist. Dass man eben einfach auf Interbank-Ebene so etwas weiter kommuniziert.
In dem Moment wo ich sage, dieses Konto ist aufgelöst, das Nachfolgekonto ist
dieses, dass dann halt herankommende Lastschriften online angezeigt werden können,
dann übernommen werden können oder nicht.
Es wäre alles lösbar, nur der Wille ist nicht da so etwas auch tatsächlich zu machen.
Ja aber dieses gesamte System, I-Bahn und Bahnkonto und so weiter,
das ist doch wirklich inzwischen einfach mal durch.
Also ganz ehrlich.
Wie fern meinst du das jetzt?
Einfach nicht angemessen in der Zeit. Was wäre denn angemessen für die Zeit?
Zum Beispiel einfach mal Möglichkeiten des Zahlungsverkehrs,
die man sich heute wünscht anzubieten.
Warum sind denn solche Systeme wie Paypal oder irgendwelche Kryptowährungsmöglichkeiten so beliebt?
Weil sie das moderne Leben abbilden, was jetzt so ein IBAN Verfahren nun wirklich nicht tut.
Da kommen wir dann gleich im nächsten Thema dazu, zu diesem Aspekt.
Aber lass mich kurz noch was zu dieser IBAN sagen, weil mal ganz unabhängig davon,
was dann in Zukunft mal vielleicht unter Umständen das ablösen wird,
ist ja auch klar, dass das jetzt nicht von heute auf morgen verschwindet,
selbst wenn man eine total geile
Alternative hätte, die heute so meiner Auffassung nach noch keiner hat.
Aber man könnte eine ganze Menge tun, um dieses IBAN-System deutlich kundenfreundlicher zu gestalten.
Eine Sache habe ich ja schon vorgeschlagen und manche Banken tun das ja auch.
Was zum Beispiel extrem hilfreich wäre, wenn ich mir eine persönliche IBAN bestellen würde.
Kaufen könnte. Das heißt, ich habe eine Kontonummer,
die nicht ein Konto bei einer Bank ist, sondern die meine IBAN ist und die ich
selber konfigurieren kann, zu welchem Konto welcher Bank sie denn nun tatsächlich durchleitet.
Sodass in dem Moment, wo ein Kontowechsel erforderlich ist,
sich meine IBAN nicht ändert und gegenüber den Leuten,
die abbuchen oder mir etwas überweisen, sich überhaupt nichts ändert,
nur das Geld bei einer anderen Bank auf einem anderen Konto landet,
aber dieses Konto wird sozusagen so nicht gesehen und wenn ich was überweise,
kann ich dann halt auch wie abgehende Rufnummer sozusagen meine persönliche
IBAN als Absender geben.
Das könnte man dann sicherstellen, dass das sozusagen nicht für Betrug genutzt
wird und das kann man auch irgendwie,
kann man look up machen und man kann auch erfahren, auf welches Bankkonto das
zeigt und so, nur dass es diesen Alias gibt, wäre ja an der Stelle schon mal eine große Hilfe.
Auch eine Technik, die es nicht gibt und die in diesem Standard so nicht vorgesehen
ist, aber es gibt natürlich auch schon Lösungen für die bestehenden Probleme,
die zumindest von manchen moderneren Banken umgesetzt werden.
Ich hab ja verschiedene ausprobiert, lobend zu erwähnen ist zum Beispiel hier Bunk,
dieses Startup-Projekt da aus Holland, da muss man nicht alles dran mögen und
so weiter und alles so mit Apps zu machen und ohne Filialen,
das ist auch nochmal so ein Schmerz in sich, aber grundsätzlich so Sachen wie
diese drohenden Fraud-Abbuchungen,
also die Lastschriften, in dem Moment wo dein Name und deine Kontonummer bekannt wird,
dann können halt Leute im Prinzip behaupten gegenüber deiner Bank,
ja hier das ist hier so, wir sind hier Vodafone, sind natürlich nicht Vodafone,
aber das schreiben sie einfach mal rein, wir müssen jetzt hier mal was abholen.
Wenn aber das erste Mal so eine Lastschrift kommt, dann ist es technisch tatsächlich
auch in diesem Bankenstandard etwas anderes als eine danach wiedererfolgende,
wiederholte Lastschrift.
Man spricht von der Erst- und von der Folge Lastschrift. Und bei Bunk ist es
zum Beispiel so, dass eben wenn eine Erstlastschrift kommt, dann wird die generell
erstmal gar nicht freigegeben.
Bevor ich die nicht explizit angenommen habe. So Sachen. Ganz einfacher Schutz.
Und das sind einfach so Sachen, die bei den Banken fehlen und die haben da auch
keine Vorkehrungen. Ich hatte zum Beispiel dieses Spendenkonto,
das ist für Lastschriften gesperrt.
Genau aus diesem Grund. Und natürlich alle Nase lang kommt dann wieder irgendein
Heini und bucht bei mir irgendwelche Services ab, die ich natürlich nie in Anspruch
genommen habe, das wird dann sofort abgelehnt, taucht dann aber auf.
Dann nehm ich mir irgendwie diese Daten, schreib meiner Bank,
sag hier Leute, hier wollte einer bei mir irgendwie was abholen.
Wo schreib ich das bei euch rein? Wo kann ich das melden?
Wo könnt ihr die Cops los schicken?
Erstmal tagelang keine Antwort, dann irgendwie konfus. Ja, ne,
wissen wir auch nicht, müssen wir mal fragen. Ich frag da nochmal.
Ja Herr Britlarff und so weiter, ja wir können da auch gar nichts mit anfangen.
Aber sie können ja eine Anzeige erstatten.
So hallo? Habt ihr sie noch alle? Ich meine das ist euer Problem,
es ist Fraud auf eurer scheiß Plattform, die ich gesprungen bin zu benutzen
und dann irgendwie ist das die Antwort?
Leute ihr habt sie doch nicht alle, ihr müsst doch die Leute in nullkommanix
dingfest machen, tausende von euren Kunden werden irgendwelche Beträge abgebucht
und euch interessiert das gar nicht? Also es ist wirklich, also Banken, echt.
Ja, da kommt irgendwie nix. Die bewegen sich einfach nicht auf einer modernen
Ebene, die dem entgegen tritt.
Wenn es modern ist, dann gibt es ja nur Konkurrenz, dann müssten sie sich ja
schnell bewegen und so weiter.
Ja, klar. Da wissen sie natürlich, dass sie dich in ihrer ...
Mit dem Ding gehalten ... Ja. Also, es ist nicht ideal, was da jetzt grade passiert ist.
Ähm ... Zeigt, wie ... wie unschön dieses ganze Set-up ist.
Aber es ist ja auch kein Weltuntergang, ja?
Äh, aber das kann natürlich jetzt noch Ewigkeiten weitergehen.
Ja, aber wahrscheinlich werden alle Betroffenen das relativ schnell merken,
dass da bei Ihnen so etwas versucht wird.
So und dann sind wir im Prinzip auch schon beim nächsten Thema,
nämlich dem Thema digitaler Euro.
Die Sinnlosigkeit dieser Formulierung will ich mich jetzt nicht groß auslassen,
aber das Ganze ist ein entsprechend benanntes Projekt der Europäischen Zentralbank, EZB.
Und das läuft auch schon eine Weile, das ist so ein öffentlich dokumentierter Gedankenprozess,
sag ich mal, dem sie dokumentieren im Web und sich dazu äußern und weil diese
Timeline jetzt demnächst,
nämlich angeblich im dritten Quartal 23 so zum Ende kommen soll und Ende 2021 angefangen hat,
Wollten wir das zumindest mal kurz aufgreifen und gucken was uns dazu einfällt.
Also vielleicht erstmal so die Situation, die EZB denkt darüber nach,
so eine, wie sie es eben nennen, digitale Euro, rein technisch betrachtet ist
jeder Euro digital, aber ist egal, ich sag mal eine online fähige Version des Euro zu entwickeln.
Also etwas, was sich nicht nur in Bargeld in Form von Münzen und Papier,
also Banknoten ausdrückt, sondern eben in irgendeiner Form elektronisch repräsentiert
werden kann und damit auch im Netz genutzt werden kann.
Die EZB sieht, dass Cash generell immer weniger genutzt wird,
in manchen Ländern mehr, in manchen Ländern weniger und dementsprechend natürlich
im E-Commerce überhaupt gar keine Rolle spielt.
Und einerseits sagen sie, dass die klassische Aufteilung der Aufgaben zwischen der Zentralbank,
die ja primär das eigentliche Geld verwaltet und dann eben an Banken verleiht,
damit dies eben auch wiederum in Form von Krediten und anderen Dienstleistungen in Umlauf bringen kann.
Und dann auf der anderen Seite eben privaten Payment-Providern,
also jetzt konkret für Bezahlfunktionen, also Kreditkarten, Girokarten und was
es daneben auch noch gibt, dass das so in der Summe ganz gut funktioniert hat,
meint zumindest die EZP.
Aber man macht sich jetzt in zunehmendem Maße wegen globaler Krisen.
Zum Beispiel Sanktionen von außen, da alle populären Payment-Provider,
gemeint sind natürlich hier vor allem Mastercard und Visa, nicht aus der EU stammen.
Jetzt haben wir ja gerade gesehen hier mit dem Konflikt mit Russland,
denn Russland ist stark sanktioniert worden und ist eben auch aus dem SWIFT
System ausgeschlossen worden und irgendwie betraf uns das ja sozusagen nur sekundär,
aber man hat sich dann eben auch mal wieder sehr viel mehr Gedanken darüber
gemacht, wie wäre denn das jetzt eigentlich, wenn man uns mal aus irgendetwas raushalten würde.
Sagen wir mal, es läuft nicht mehr so gut zwischen den USA und Europa,
aus welchen Gründen auch immer, weil sie wahrscheinlich wieder irgend so ein
Vollhorst ins Präsidentenamt gewählt haben.
Und was wäre denn dann, wenn dann auf einmal Visa und Massacrat hier nicht mehr
funktioniert. Das sehen sie also sozusagen als Problem.
Dazu kommt noch, dass in der Öffentlichkeit so ein bisschen Konfusion darüber
entstanden ist in den letzten Jahren, was digitales Geld eigentlich jetzt wirklich ist.
Und durch solche Trends wie zum Beispiel diesen ganzen Kryptounsinn,
über den wir uns ja hier nur in den letzten Jahren deutlich geäußert haben,
sie bezeichnen das übrigens interessanterweise als Crypto-Assets.
Also sie sprechen nicht von Währung, ganz bewusst, weil ist keine.
Und die Ineffizienz, die mit diesem System verbunden ist und natürlich auch
insbesondere in Form von sogenannten Stable Coins,
also die angeblich direkt ja mit richtigen Währungen in Korrelation stehen,
dass dann halt so die Gefahr von solchen Bankruns entsteht.
Ist ja auch passiert, gerade im letzten Jahr, also da haben wir jetzt nicht
so viel drüber geredet, aber in dieser ganzen Kryptobranche,
da geht ja eine Pleitewelle, folgt der nächsten. Das geht alles gerade ordentlich unter.
Aber aus Sicht der EZB gefährdet das eben das System als solches.
Also Sie sehen einfach durch diese ganze Debatte um Kryptoassets ist einfach
diese ganze Idee des Geldsystems einfach sehr schwierig geworden,
das noch in irgendeiner Form zu steuern und korrekt zu kommunizieren,
was denn jetzt hier eigentlich gilt.
Und außerdem hat die EZB so ein bisschen Angst, dass so künftig Big Tech Companies,
wie sie das übrigens selbst nennen, selber irgendwelche Stablecoins rausbringen.
Hatten wir auch schon den Fall, das war Facebooks Versuch, ich hab jetzt gerade
vergessen wie sie dieses System genannt haben, erinnerst du dich da noch dran?
Sie wollten so ein Libra oder so was genau.
Und das war sozusagen Facebooks Attacke auf das Ganze.
Und das hat der EZB auch überhaupt nicht gefallen. Das ist ja auch gescheitert
an dem Widerstand und so, aber naja.
Jetzt gibt es also diesen globalen Trend, sogenannte CBDCs rauszubringen.
Das steht für Central Bank Digital Currencies.
Also quasi eine digitale Repräsentation der Währung, die von diesen Zentralbanken
vorgehalten werden. Im Falle der EZB ist das natürlich der Euro.
Und die EU hat jetzt so ein bisschen Angst da abgehängt zu werden,
weil andere Länder das voran breiten.
Ich kann jetzt gerade keine Beispiele nennen, wer das jetzt eigentlich gerade
aktiv gerade voran treibt.
Vielleicht kannst du da selber nochmal schauen, Linus.
Auf jeden Fall gibt es die Meinung, dass so diese CDBCs,
CBDCs, so rum, Basismoderner Bezahldienstleistungen werden könnten,
ohne dass man das sozusagen über Banken direkt machen muss.
Also dass man in irgendeiner Form Euro von A nach B schieben kann,
ohne dass eben diesen Umweg eines Bankkontos zu machen.
Und so quasi so generellen unmittelbaren Zugriff zu diesen Werten zu haben. Das ist so ein bisschen die Idee dabei.
Als Grundlagen dafür, was erreicht werden müsste, sagen sie, dass es halt ein System sein müsste, was eine hohe Akzeptanz hat, was leicht zu bedienen sein soll, wenig Kosten aufwirft, schnell abgewickelt werden kann, sicher ist und den Konsumenten schützt und obendrauf muss auch noch die Privatsphäre gesichert sein.
Aber ich verstehe überhaupt nicht, wo das hin soll und es ist eben nicht dezentral, ganz im Gegenteil, ungefähr das Zentralste, was du machen kannst. Es gibt keine technische...
Ausdefinition. Das heißt, da schreiben jetzt irgendwelche Leute,
so soll das funktionieren, und dann werden die das wahrscheinlich,
dann werden die das irgendwann ausschreiben.
Und dann gehen irgendwelche Leute wieder hin, die wieder keine, also,
und sagen dann, wir implementieren jetzt, was ihr euch da gedacht habt,
was vorher keiner technischen Betrachtung, ja, unterzogen wurde.
Also ich sehe nicht genau, was, wohin das soll. Verstehe es wirklich nicht.
Naja also letzten Endes würde es ja bedeuten, dass du ein Konto bei der Zentralbank
führst. So ne und das wäre dann so quasi dein persönliches Konto. Du würdest halt nicht.
Ja die kriegen, die schreiben im Juli darüber ja mit irgendwie Key Objectives
and Design Considerations brauchen die zwei Seiten für.
Ja das ist ein zwei Seiten Dokument.
Naja hat ja keiner gesagt, dass es einfach ist.
Ja, also warten wir mal ab, aber irgendwie, ich meine, es hat noch gar keine
technische Definition.
Es soll allerdings irgendwie so eine Möglichkeit geben, sich tatsächlich das
Geld dann runterzuladen.
Also, dass du dir quasi wirklich heruntergeladenes Bargeld auf dein Handy legst.
Und dann frage ich mich spätestens, dann brauchen sie irgendeine Lösung für
das Double Spending Problem.
Und da das aber Konto getrieben ist oder statt Münzen getrieben,
bin ich mal gespannt wie du mit einem zentralen System einerseits irgendwas
von Anonymität versprechen willst und andererseits das Double Spending Problem löst.
Anonymität war hier nicht die Rede, nur von Privatsphäre die geschützt werden soll.
Ja, siehst du da hat doch schon keiner mehr Bock drauf. Weiß ich nicht.
Ich will nicht unbedingt anonymes, du meinst jetzt als Alternative zu Bargeld,
dass es genauso anonym ist wie Bargeld.
Ja, aber was ist denn, also warum soll ich jetzt noch ein Konto haben?
Ich bin doch froh, ich habe genug Konten.
Die meisten Konten, die ich habe, habe ich unfreiwillig eröffnet.
Warum will ich jetzt noch eins haben, wenn mir das keinen Zweck bietet?
Übrigens ist das zwar direkt bei der Zentralbank, aber trotzdem verwaltet durch
einen Eurokontoanbieter, der im Zweifelsfall wieder deine Bank ist.
Also mir ist überhaupt nicht klar, welchen Bedarf, den ich habe.
Löst das? Welches Problem in meinem Leben habe ich dann nicht mehr, wenn ich das mache?
Das ist eine gute Frage und ich weiß nicht, ob ich darauf eine Antwort habe.
Ich beschreibe ja nur, was da gerade an Gedanken stattfindet.
Aber du würdest ja auch sofort unterschreiben, dass es schon ein Problem sein kann,
Dass der Internetzahlungsverkehr jetzt komplett einfach von Visa,
Mastercard und mit Einschränkungen auch von Paypal sozusagen definiert wird,
während es daneben keine Lösung gibt und wir oft genug das Problem hatten,
dass Sanktionen sperren und so weiter, also wenn's Russland betrifft,
dann machen wir uns vielleicht nicht so viele Gedanken darüber,
aber sollte es uns dann eben doch mal betreffen, dann stehen wir schön da und
dann hast du halt irgendwie nix so.
Ist dann schon eine Frage, ob du dann eben über so ein System quasi von Zentralbank
zu Zentralbank Geldtransaktionen dann vielleicht auf eine Art und Weise sicherstellen kannst,
dass eben diese Systeme nicht exklusiv sind im Weiterreichen von Währungen international
insbesondere, aber eben auch beim Abbuchen von Dingen.
Da müssen wir mal irgendwie so einen Heavy Shopper fragen, der hat ja gesagt
welches Problem da gerade existiert.
Vielleicht bin ich da ein bisschen naiv, aber ich hab so ein bisschen das Gefühl
noch, dass die EZB sich über diese ganzen Sachen etwas tiefer Gedanken macht,
als es jetzt eine einzelne Bank tut.
Ich sehe eben in Deutschland immer noch, also ich hab auch so eine Bank und
die erzählt mir jetzt auch irgendwas von, ich könnte ja hier auch noch in irgendwelchen
Krypto Sachen anlegen, da sag ich nur Leute, geht mir aus der Sonne,
was redet ihr für eine Scheiße.
Und zack musst du wieder Konto wechseln, weil dein Geld bei der Bank liegt,
die dich in irgendwelche Krypto Scams schieben möchte.
Aber ganz ehrlich, die Statements der EZB, der Zentralbank, zu diesem ganzen
Kryptounsinn, waren von Anfang an ganz klar.
Die haben von Anfang an genau benannt, was sie für Probleme da sehen und die
haben auch ihre Meinung dahingehend überhaupt nicht geändert.
Das fand ich schon sehr straight.
Also ich hab schon so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass die da einfach …
Ja klar, aber gut, ja stimmt, aber wenn irgendwie so Satoshi Nakamoto schreibt,
hier Zentralbanken sind ein Problem, auf Seite 1 und auf Seite 2 irgendwie Bitcoin
erklärt, dann muss die Zentralbank auch nicht so smart sein,
um zu sagen, Leute halt ich finde es eine schlechte Idee.
Also dass eine Zentralbank erstens Bitcoin für eine schlechte Idee hält und
zweitens auch versteht, warum das potenziell aus Sicht einer Zentralbank eine
schlechte Idee ist, ist jetzt auch nicht, also das hätte ich schon gehofft.
Also wenn meine Zentralbank gesagt hätte, Leute, geile Sache hier Bitcoin,
nehmt die Kohle mit Schneeschippen und werft sie da rein, das wäre jetzt noch
weniger zu erwarten gewesen, oder?
Ja also, da hast du natürlich recht, so, aber irgendwie hab ich das,
aber sie waren die einzigen die das geschrieben haben.
Also alle anderen haben sich diesem Hype hingegeben und gerade wo du das sagst,
also gerade so diese Vorstellungen von Zentralbanken sind ein Problem.
Da kann ich nur sagen, Leute, get your act together.
Ja, aber das war der Auslöser der Bitcoin-Effekte.
Ja, natürlich, klar, aber das ist halt einfach mal im Kern libertäres Gedankengut,
was halt irgendwie die Idee von Privatgeld und letzten Endes dem Schutz der Reichen ausdrückt.
Nichts anderes ist das. Und das ganze unter dieser Maske des allgemeinen Wohlstands
irgendwelcher unterdrückter Unbanker in Indien, Afrika und Asien.
Das ist einfach sowas von falsch. Tatsächlich steckt einfach in dieser ganzen
Krypto-Ideologie nichts anderes drin, als dieses libertäre Gedankengut,
mit der Staat soll sich raushalten.
Und ganz ehrlich, wenn es ums Geld geht, nee, der Staat soll sich da nicht raushalten.
Ganz im Gegenteil, der ist genau das System, was die Stabilität dieser Währung
und dass das irgendwie auch einen gleichen Zugang dazu gibt,
aufrechterhalten kann.
Das mag nicht immer in allen Momenten ideal gelöst sein, aber durch die Einführung
von Zentralbanken haben wir überhaupt erstmal sowas wie ein globales Wirtschaftssystem,
was halbwegs funktioniert. Und das ist halt etwas, was viele Leute sich so nicht
klar machen und sich einfach einreden lassen.
Zentralbanken wären jetzt in irgendeiner Form irgendwas böses,
weil die sind ja zentral.
Nur die Dezentralbanken, die sie jetzt hier vorgeschlagen haben,
das sind einfach nur Scanner-Bauer-Nepper-Bauernfänger.
Also wirklich, das geht gar nicht. Egal. Digitaler Euro ist eine Idee,
wird diskutiert, im Herbst kriegen wir nochmal eine Wiedervorlage,
da bin ich mal sehr gespannt, was sie da technisch zu bieten haben.
Ich persönlich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sich irgendetwas heutzutage nennenswert
durchsetzen wird, was nicht tief in Betriebssystemen von populären Plattformen sich verankern lässt.
Da wird es also mit einer digitalen Euro-App nicht getan sein.
Da muss man also schon über Standards nachdenken, die dann aber auch global funktionieren.
Sprich es kann eigentlich nur einen einzigen CBDC-Standard geben,
der weltweit funktioniert und das wird auch die EZB so alleine wahrscheinlich
auch überhaupt nicht durchsetzen können.
Andererseits hat sie natürlich als einer der, je nachdem wie man zählen will,
zwei, drei, drei, vier großen Currencies auf diesem Planeten durchaus da auch
was zu melden und ich find's auch gut, wenn die mal darüber nachdenken,
wie das so ist mit dem ganzen digitalen Raum und dem Internet wird auch langsam Zeit.
Okay, ich will erst mal wissen, welches Problem die für mich lösen und dann
vielleicht will ich dann auch einen digitalen Euro haben.
Wobei ich kann jetzt auch nicht sagen, dass ich es gerne hätte.
Aber es soll ein Kritis-Dach-Gesetz geben.
Kritis-Dach-Gesetz, im Prinzip also ein für die Sicherheit kritischer Infrastrukturen,
spezifisch natürlich auch die IT-Sicherheit, soll es also ein Unternehmen geben,
das könnte man im Prinzip sehen wie so ein bisschen das IT-Sicherheitsgesetz
3, ja, das sich spezifisch um die Lebensadern unserer Gesellschaft kümmern soll.
Also kritische Infrastrukturen in IT-Sicherheit, aber eben auch im physischen
Schutz zusammendenken und so soll das kommen, weil wir mit dem IT-Sicherheitsgesetz
nur um die IT-Sicherheit kümmern.
Wir müssen auch um physischer Schutz und der Russe greift jetzt bald die Kläranlage
an und so weiter und so fort.
So, jetzt sollte da ein Entwurf kommen von Nancy Faeser und der eigene Koalitionspartner,
in diesem Fall die Grünen, kritisiert schon seit längerem und insbesondere der Konstantin von Notz,
der ja bei den Grünen im Prinzip der innere Sicherheit und Bürgerrechte-Experte ist.
Ja, der ist eigentlich jemand, der sich wahrscheinlich gut für das Justizministerium
oder das Innenministerium bei den Grünen in Stellung gebracht hat,
dann aber dummerweise Pech hatte,
dass der Robert Habeck aus dem gleichen Bundesland kommt, glaube ich.
Sonst hätte der Konstantin von Notz sicherlich inzwischen eine solche Rolle
in der Bundesregierung.
Jetzt sagt er, wird Zeit, dass das mal kommt. Und die Hausaufgabe hatte natürlich
Nancy Und jetzt sagt der Konstantin von Notz, wäre gut, wenn das mal langsam kommt.
Nächste Woche sollte er ja mal kommen. Eigentlich sollte der ja vor der parlamentarischen
Sommerpause vorliegen.
Und jetzt erfährt man, dass ein erster Referentenentwurf bereits in Hintergrundgesprächen
an Journalistinnen und Journalisten verteilt wird, noch bevor er bei den Leuten
aus dem Parlament liegt.
Und natürlich auch, bevor jemals Verbände, Zivilgesellschaft oder so angehört worden wären, ja.
Das ist natürlich, also Nancy Faeser, was wird sie erwarten?
Das ist schon wirklich ärgerlich, dass sie da jetzt ein solches Gesetz mal wieder,
und es gab ja bei all diesen Gesetzen zu Sicherheit und Digitalisierung und
so weiter, Da beklagen wir uns immer wieder, dass die Leute nicht beteiligt werden.
Das BMI rennt ja noch groß rum und sagt, ja, nächstes Mal beteiligen wir euch.
Jetzt hier bei der E-ID, meine Güte, da werden wir euch aber beteiligen,
Leute. Da werden wir euch beteiligen, bis ihr nicht mehr beteiligt werden wollt.
Und jetzt irgendwie so ein wichtiges Gesetz zeigen sie doch nicht mal ihrem Koalitionspartner.
Da fragt man sich wirklich, wie diese Bundesregierung da noch arbeitet.
Ich weiß nicht, ob Nancy Faeser sich überhaupt noch als Teil der Bundesregierung
sieht oder ob sie sich schon als Teil der Landesregierung von Hessen wieder wahrnimmt.
Aber klar, da wird es offenbar wieder ein schlecht gemachtes Gesetz geben,
was sie sich nicht wirklich trauen, den Leuten zu zeigen.
Wo sie im Prinzip das Input vom Koalitionspartner schon fürchten,
sodass sie es lieber direkt der Presse warm reden.
Bevor sie es der Öffentlichkeit zeigen. Das finde ich schon ein bisschen sehr schade.
Ja, und wie geht es da jetzt weiter?
Naja, früher oder später wird das ja in der Öffentlichkeit liegen und dann können
wir es auch sehen, aber es ist schon, ja, das, ja, viel mehr kann ich nicht sagen.
Naja, offenbar kursiert ja etwas, ja, aber...
Irgendwie.
Nicht bei uns.
Ja mal schauen, ich gucke mal, ob es schon irgendwo noch jemand geleakt hat.
Naja gleichzeitig, achso, wenn man das sucht, findet man Bundesrechnungshof
moniert, studiere IT-Sicherheit bei den Bundesbehörden.
Das ist dann so der, aber ok, das ist vom Ende letzten Jahres,
das hat ja nur jemand verlinkt.
Tja, also ich weiß, es ist halt wieder so eine, wir machen es irgendwie.
Jetzt hat sie es offenbar erst den Journalisten gezeigt und jetzt,
wo die sich öffentlich beschweren, dann auch zur Stellungnahme an die anderen Ressorts geschickt.
Naja, aber so als erstes mal der Presse.
Gut, wenn die anderen Ressourcesters bekommen, dann wird es jetzt nicht mehr
so lange dauern, bis dieser Entwurf kommt. Dann werden sich natürlich viele
darüber beschweren. Ah, ich sehe gerade hier, der Falk Steiner hat den auch schon vorliegen.
Das ist ja ein Journalist in dem Bereich.
Das heißt, da werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich in der nächsten Sendung,
wenn das nicht unsere Sendung beim Camp ist, darüber sprechen können.
So kommen wir eigentlich zum Schluss jetzt, oder?
Du hast noch einen kleinen Scherz zum Ende drin.
Kleiner Scherz.
Und zwar geht es um Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Facebook und der NSO Group.
NSO sind ja die Hersteller von.
Pegasus, dem wahrscheinlich fortschrittlichsten bekannten Schadsoftware-System
für Android und iOS, das immer wieder von sich reden macht. Wir erinnern uns
an den Pegasus-Untersuchungsausschuss und so weiter und so fort.
Und ich glaube, es war vor ungefähr zwei Jahren oder so, oder schon länger her,
dass Facebook im Prinzip sich angestrengt hat, gegen die NSO Group vorzugehen.
Dass dass sie die nämlich gesagt haben, hier, ihr habt ja ein spezifisches Modul gegen Whatsapp,
damit habt ihr viele tausend Leute überwacht und dann hat sich quasi auch Facebook
quasi gegen NSO gewendet und hat dann ihre Anwälte dahin geschickt,
was wir natürlich schön fanden, weil, genauso wie wir es schön finden,
wenn Mark Zuckerberg Elon Musk in der Telefonzelle trifft.
Finden wir schön, wenn Facebook die NSO-Group verklagt, weil wahrscheinlich
hat Facebook ein etwas größeres Budget für ihre Rechtsabteilung.
So und jetzt kommt, da ist es ein bisschen ruhig geworden und es ist auch in
der Meldung jetzt gar nicht so klar, ob das wirklich in diesem Court Case ist oder in einem anderen.
Das ist noch nicht so hundertprozentig klar. Aber was wird jetzt gemeldet, Tim?
Dass Facebook selber Pegasus kaufen wollte und zum Einsatz bringen wollte.
Also das ganze Unternehmen oder Lizenzen?
So wie ich das verstanden habe wollten sie nur dieses Produkt haben und ja das ganze hat auch so ein bisschen so eine Vorgeschichte, es gab ja auch mal so diese Nummer, dass Facebook irgendwie so ein VPN Produkt rausgebracht hat, das Onavoprotect hieß das irgendwie.
So ist es.
Genau.
Ich hoffe die kommen da einfach gar nicht mehr raus aus der Telefonzelle.
Ich muss auch zugeben, dass ich gerade in Telefonzellen Beispiel hier gegenseitig
laufe, parallel laufe, weil meine Google Ergebnisse für Telefonzelle jetzt so
gewisse Färbung haben in Richtung Auseinandersetzung.
Verlinken wir nicht, guckt euch das nicht an, ist falsch.
Schlecht. Einfach zuck und Elon in die Telefonzelle rein und sagen so hier das ist euer Fight.
Nur einer kommt raus.
Ja das sagen wir denen aber es kommt natürlich keiner raus. Einfach zumachen
Gaffa Tape drum und irgendwo in den Wald stellen und gut ist,
dann können sie ja ihre Liebe zueinander entdecken.
Okay, warte mal, das heißt, jetzt ist das Camp bald? So bald ist das gar nicht,
ne, ist noch fast ein Monat.
Und wir machen jetzt erstmal Schluss.
Wir machen jetzt erstmal Schluss.
Leute, es wird jetzt wahrscheinlich auch erstmal nicht so viel Logbuch geben
bis zum Camp, also vielleicht.
Man merkt doch, das ist so ein Schwerfeld Themen zu finden, ne, also es kommen.
Das hast du gesagt. Also es ist natürlich generell News dünne Zeit aber jetzt
ist halt auch gerade der Fokus auf noch ein bisschen Sommerurlaub einerseits
und auch aufs Camp andererseits,
also wir gucken, dass wir noch Termine finden und die dann auch machen,
aber verlasst euch mal bis zum Camp nicht so auf den Wochenrhythmus.
Ja, okay.
Das war es dann erstmal von uns.
Bis dahin.
Alle Regler auf 11 und Tschüss.
Tschau tschau.